سالنا السيدات بكل صراحه هل تخشين على
زوجك من صديقاتك المقربات
[موسيقى]
تبقى صاحبتك المقربه ولبست فرند ومش عارف
ايه وكل ده وفجاه في يوم وليله تقلب عليك
عشان خاطر جوزك يعني انا شخص اصحابي بس لا
الصراحه مش هاثق في جوزي ثقه كامله لا ما
هم اصحابي وهو جوزي لسبب لان انا اصلا
واثقه فيهم هم الاثنين فان انا لو انا مش
واثقه فيه ما كنتش ما كانوش دول هيكونوا
اصحابي اولادها هيكون جوزي هو المفروض ان
انا صاحبهم على اساس ان انا واثقه فيهم ان
انا همم على جوزي كده وبرده واثقه في جوزي
يعني كنت مش هتجوز ايه اكيد ما اهو يعني
ممكن ناثق في واحده بس انا متاكده ان انا
واثقه ان هي عشره عمري انما مثلا يبقى ما
يبقاش صحابي البنات الثانيين العاديين
ويجيء بتجيء واحده فيهم تقعد جنبه وتقعد
تهزر معه وابقى قاعده يعني مش كيس جوافه
ههه
[موسيقى]